welcome back to New rockstars and
Ant-Man and the wasp's quantumania
revealed that the Council of Kings have
been playing with time like children
decided the face of everyone in the time
stream but what if I told you that
quantumania Kang wasn't the only black
on black violence that is going to
happen on a multiversal scale what if I
told you that the biggest threat to the
Council of Kings was none other than
Eric killmonger get ready for Krieg 3.14
cause it's Infinity baby killmonger
Infinity
um
killmonger Power kill magnify uh this is
Roque Theory the show and we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is Mt and Greg
rogersby today is the one and only the
wonderful the amazing Whitney Van Line
what's going on with me hi hello I'm
sorry to repeat myself but I said this
off camera I don't think that the three
of us should be allowed to do this I
think we need we need someone to
supervise I'm a little yeah I guess we
should have informed the United Nations
beforehand
um things are going to go we really
should have informed the U.S
we should have informed the UN and she
yes shield first
um actually Shield blast because they're
secretly Hydra and the cousin of Modoc
and we are both the cousins of Modoc uh
big head gang let's go Tommy Beck told
what's going on yo if we're still
serving up killmonger pie serve me two
slices of that ass
like I Creed Three has too much muscle
like that movie has too much muscle like
it's just too much there are so many abs
in that movie there is only ass like
they better get the Magic Mike cleanup
crew for every theater because I don't
think it's gonna be it's not gonna be
the same after that one they gotta bring
down the seats yeah you gotta spray down
every seat this is gonna be me
[Laughter]
uh but yes I'm so glad to have you guys
on this Rogue Theory it's gonna be a
nice three Banger we call the three bags
we call it a three bang here at the new
Rockstar's office shout out to producer
Brandon who coined that term my favorite
terms but yes our first topic is
killmonger is coming for the Council of
Kings now at least that's what I believe
and this is why I believe this because
we you remember from the end of what if
which is a Marvel Studios Production
within the MCU Canon the end of what if
ends with killmonger and Zola fighting
for the Infinity Stones to try to be
like the successor to Ultron infinity
and to just go around the Multiverse and
correcting things now let's say
killmonger takes those jewels from that
Nazi [__] and puts them on and he's
like all right it's time for me to find
out about the Multiverse and he learns
about the secret Clubhouse somewhere
with all those kings and how they
allowed slavery remember slavery not
great not great just saying not ideal
not a good
um I'm on record as being anti Slater
in advance but I I admire it I don't I
don't want to ruffle the Waters of rope
here I've always been I've always said
no to slavery so yeah you know that is
ideal I guess I'm not like other guys I
guess I've just built different does not
like the other girls
I like getting muddy I like horses I
like going for walks I'm not like your
average girl um yo I seen you with the
horses you wear short skirts and I wear
t-shirts okay
but I'm on the bleachers baby I'm on the
bleachers getting getting muddy Whitney
when we um say Taylor Swift's lyrics we
put our hand over our hearts what are
you doing
the whole time
[Music]
I don't listen to Taylor Swift I I
belong to Ali and AJ Supremacy
um that's that's all I believe in that's
true white girls that's true honestly
the the Potential Breakup Song with
explicit lyrics so it's so good that
song
so absolutely so it's the version that
Disney should have released first let's
be honest should have released in the
beginning they should have been like my
[__] birthday the whole time that
should have been another classic I like
my stupid birthday I like the Miranda
you like the stupid oh my gosh get back
on track all right I said I was gonna
keep this on that's hilarious thank you
get back on track thank you very much
but no speaking of Alan agent killmonger
yeah
um yeah Ally and AJ killmonger
as you can say the kilma the Ali and AJ
have the answer that's what everyone
says but no uh but yes no this this idea
of of Kang's authoring slavery because
we know that killmonger is very very um
passionate about the African struggle um
across the world um the black struggle
and if killmonger learns
um that Kang a black man
and like all these other kings other
black men thought that slavery was cool
and like there's a freaking guy Rama Tut
who literally has slaves
um in Egypt
um and dresses up like a like a slave
owner all the time I think that
killmonger is going to be pretty upset
um at least a little bit and I think
that there was a chance horrible cosplay
idea yeah absolutely terrible costume
yeah there's a chance that we could see
killmonger Infinity attack the Council
of Kings
um what do you guys think of this
possibility of um killmonger Infinity
going after the Council of kings and to
have his revenge because they're not
like I can't they came from quantumania
is not the only enemies that the castle
of King have now like there's two people
out there that have big grieving that
would have big grievances with the
counts of kings and and then with that
you're saying you're saying Kang from
quantumania is alive which I believe yes
I I believe yeah oh yeah he's for sure
alive there's no way he's dead he's dead
like the Scarlet Witch pretty much
we know he's in the probability spy
you're right I think you're I think I
think that I know I think we're
absolutely correct I think both are
alive uh I empty I think this this makes
a lot of sense the uh I mean you have
two angry forces right Kang is angry
because they're elitist right they can
are by Nature feel their Superior beings
their anger comes from being frustrated
by you know not being able to get
exactly what they want when they want it
how they want it at all times like all
true narcissists killmonger's anger
comes from Injustice and whether it's
perceived or real you know I mean
there's definitely some real Injustice
that he's fighting but in 2023 the
injustices you know are are he's he's
he's he's he's trying to stitch up Old
Wounds which is hard to do so I think
that the anger from killmonger versus
The Anger from king would be an
explosive battle and I think that
probably one that would distract the
Council of Kang's enough to allow
Avengers to get some work done as well
in defeating them so I love this Theory
I think it's great I like it I like that
I like that idea of the Avengers
um just like sneaky and just like all
right kill mugger you go do the thing
yeah and we're just gonna go behind you
guys Tucker each other out about the
Scooby gangs
you kids go crazy we're just gonna find
the plug and unplug this whole operation
go nuts boys is Kang taking a nap yeah
he's all tuckered he's all tuckered up
and find a killmonger
it's like when your parents used to take
you to Chuck E cheese and let you get
loaded up
and they would just sit in the back and
drink wine and you'd run all the [__]
around the Chuck E cheese until you got
tuckered out yeah that was that's what
that's what we're doing to Kang and
killmonger baby we're giving them Surge
and letting them loosen a Chuck E cheese
I like it I like it Whitney do you like
it I do and here's the number one reason
why I like it because as Mt bench
mentioned in the beginning which I just
want to say I know I know you phrased it
like this for me and thank you but we
need to remember that his name is Eric
killmonger and then we have Nathaniel
Kang so it's really just a battle
between Eric and Nate maybe Eric and
Nate going head
Eric battling me two kids on the
playground duking it out on the
tetherball Court let's go that's what I
want to see if they make that a project
I want to see Eric V Nate as the as the
title
oh we're gonna make t-shirts we're gonna
make [__] T-shirts if this happens
Eric V Nate team Eric teammate
but no um I like that a lot
um but oh my God I just I I really want
what if at least at the very least to
tackle this question because like you
know what if season two is coming and
the the portal has been opened for what
if characters to appear in movies right
we have Captain Britain has made it onto
the screen so it's like uh you know we
even had a zombie strange albeit not
necessarily the zombies strange so yeah
you know I I think I'm all about it
empty I'm all about it if you want me to
vote I'll vote you let me know when it's
time if if you like because like if you
think about it Marvel what if is just
Rogue Theory animated pretty much like
this yes it broke Theory the Animated
Series it's smarter but like if they
want to take any of our ideas to make it
to episodes that like more than happy
more than happy to give those out yeah
but if you take any idea just letting
you know Kevin feige if you take any
ideas from Rogue Theory you have to
specify that they're part of the MTS
the master attainment yes only
um located my imagination currently oh
I'm just kidding but no let's vote on
this what do you guys think of this idea
of killmonger
um attacking the accounts uh a rogus I
vote rogus okay I know last time I gave
this I know I know empties I gave you a
bogus on the last time I was on the show
and I was banned for a month I'm not
making that mistake again I'm going
rogus but I'm giving you a legit rogus I
love this Theory it brings two of my
favorite characters multiple Kings I
love King killmonger is maybe my
favorite character in the MCU he's
definitely up there for me I just love
the way Michael B Jordan plays him I was
thrilled so good he came back
you know I don't necessarily I don't
necessarily agree with all the killing
well thank you and oh I saw the rogus
from Whitney so double rogus all around
yeah no I'm I'm double roasting because
I love this Theory so hard I want to see
ABS on apps
and Eric just just go and really Ham on
each other that's totally what I was
just grinding the washboards together
dude yeah I was gonna say just two
washboards clanging together like a
goddamn cheese grater you stick a block
of cheese between their abs and you just
make them do a little dance
perfectly grated cheddar oh my God
that's how you make nachos let's go
that's how you make nachos for sure
girl this was great thank you guys for
um hearing my really weird Theory but
really fun Theory uh but up next Tommy
has a rogue theory about Modoc which is
going to be pretty great but first be
sure to check out nerd riot.shop we can
always grab the latest and greatest new
rockstars gear our brand new Mandalorian
inspired merch is now available in this
shop it's amazing and you can bring it
home warm or you can bring it home cold
just like the Mandalorian and we're
bringing back shout outs for Mandalorian
gear when you pick up a piece of
Mandalorian inspired merch you unlock
the opportunity to get a custom shout
out that will appear on Wikileaks our
Mandalorian after show it's an amazing
show
um so support the channel and check out
all of our great merch options over at
nerd riot.shop today but this leads us
to our second topic for today which will
be presented by the lovely Tommy let's
take it away Tommy well thank you for
calling me lovely uh and I want to
mention I what I I was wearing a man a
Mandalorian uh a shirt from our the way
collection at nerd riot.shop but I
spilled some juice sonnet so now I'm
wearing a quantumania shirt from our
Quantum media collection which is still
available and I'd like to mention
that made me pivot my theory I was going
to do a Mando Theory I spilled on the
shirt I said this is a bad Omen so I'm
whipping this Theory out of The Archives
this is in my theory Theory cabinet here
it comes uh this is the path I see to
getting Modoc back in the MCU I mean you
give us Modoc it's a little ridiculous
it's a lot of fun and I think that it's
natural for people to want that
character to come back I don't think
we're getting down crosses Modoc back I
do think we are going to get modox back
in the MCU and here's how I believe once
the introduction of Dr Doom is made into
the MCU he's going to bail out a certain
Tech billionaire who's been in jail for
a long time some people think he died
because of that one shot I know he's
alive because it's been confirmed Justin
Hammond I love him oh Justin Hammer is
going to obtain Black Market pin
particles perhaps from the power broker
or some Black Market PP
yeah
[Laughter]
till you try it there's a reason there's
a reason why I've never lost a job
because of a drug test
J hams in the black market PP that's our
new band name y'all oh my God oh my God
hammer time now here so so we've got the
pin particles now we're gonna need a
mercenary some sort of soldier to go
down into the quantum realm to retrieve
modoc's body I believe Hammer has all
the power in the world to find you know
a former Hydra agent or a former Shield
operative that they can train to go down
there they're going to get modoc's body
back now an important element of modox
costume in Ant-Man in the WASP Quantum
media was that heart rate monitor why
was that so important why do we need to
know bodox vitals because we needed to
know when he died and we need to know
when the machine is operational and
because you get that heartbeat now in
the comics modak has played uh is is is
Created from a man named George Tarleton
I believe there's going to that Justin
Hammer is going to kind of recreate aim
from uh what's his name Audrey Audrey or
uh Adrian Killian Eldridge Killian
Aldridge Killian he's gonna take over
start a new one right
Ansel Al lingard uh no so I think I
think that Justin Hammer is going to
restart aim there's going to be a
technician named George Tarleton who's
going to volunteer to be made into the
new Modoc that way we don't have to make
Darren cross keep doing this ridiculous
I don't want to be a dick anymore he
just he had his Redemption Arc I think
he's dead as Modoc I believe George
Tarleton will appear as a new Modoc
funded by Justin Hammer uh through the
means of Doctor Doom to fight on behalf
of aim which will be controlled by Doom
going forward in the MCU I yield to you
all now to discuss bro what if what if
George Charlton just saw the clip of
modoc's tiny butt and he was like
I wanted a tiny little butt just like
that tiny little boy the ideal male form
like yeah why not what if that's his
thing that's fine feel your feelings
honestly everybody is a beautiful body
he has a very beautiful body and I like
this idea of modoc's return so much
because like at the end of the day like
like in the Marvel Comics modox is a
computer and like you can reuse a
computer repurpose a computer and like
basically scoop a computer out and like
put a new processing system in and um
yeah I think that having
um George Tarleton be Modoc if the next
Modoc would be a really fun way to
continue that character while like you
said keeping Darren cross's sacrifice
um intact because I really enjoy that
part of the film uh I think that I I
might be in the minority here
um but like I really not
on the show I thought he had a great
character Arc I liked him so much he's
just a he's a weird little guy that is
the character archetype that he is
everything every piece of media needs at
least one exactly yeah and he's just a
weird little guy and I want to see that
weird little guy again because it's
stupid it's stupid he looks stupid he
looks dumb and I love it I love how dumb
he is guys the proof is in the pudding
look at Fox news an entire network made
of weird little guys it's the most
popular thing
bro like Modoc and like Matt Gates got
the same forehead bro I'm still telling
you bro dude Modoc having a newsman show
oh my God Modoc should be a Newsmax
anchor they already kind of look angry
enough they're like pretty much Modoc on
Infowars all right
is there anything left to discuss are
you guys ready to vote on this bad baby
oh we can't vote
[Music]
let's put on this
rogus bogus or August well I guess you
guys said Whitney um I guess it's just
me and Whitney yeah um what do you think
Whitney yeah it's that it's not you guys
it's us
oh man my favorite my favorite kind uh
no this is this is so roguez I want a
weird little guy back in my life I I had
two too few moments with that weird
little guy and I want him to come back
also I just have to say really quick
this is slightly separate but my
favorite kind of humor obviously if you
could not tell by the rest of the
episode is
really evil guys with really normal
things just
super normal and like so the whole time
every time the joke was
I I was scream laughing in the theater
because that is my exact sense of humor
and I was so happy that that was the
joke that they kept making
so guys Eric killmonger or Eric Magneto
or Nate Kang it's like what is it just
normal ass guy names
I'm into it I totally agree with Whitney
like this I just didn't want more Modoc
in the MCU and like having George
toddleton
um come in and like actually make a
comic book accurate Modoc um ideally I
would love Jaleel White
um this is very very random Steve Urkel
um
so amazing could we put suspenders on
the Modoc body that would be so funny
but yeah I think that he would make an
amazing Monarch that'd be hilarious I
love it look at this Clean Sweep of
froakies yes we're all going rogus today
this is for everybody uh but no thank
you all around but now it's time for our
Rogue question um but before we go to
the real question I know that I um asked
you guys to tweet out your Rogue
theories using the hashtag Rogue Theory
and please keep doing that with the
hashtag Rogue theory on Twitter
um so we we can see your Rogue theories
um and to talk about them in a future
episode of work Theory but anyway now
it's time for our Rogue question you
guys ready yeah oh hell yeah baby let's
go yes because speaking of Jonathan
Majors versus
um Eric Kim all right Michael B Jordan I
like that his name for a second this one
this weekend Creed 3 is fighting its way
into theaters where we will actually get
to see killmonger and King Face Off in
the boxing ring via their actor avatars
Michael B Jordan and Jonathan Majors
what two MCU heroes or villains would
you like to see go 12 rounds of the Ring
I'd like to see Thanos in the Hulk fight
again again okay Thanos in the Hulk
fight all right did we get of genuine
Thanos and we didn't really get a
genuine Thanos in Hulk fight honestly I
I agree with this because you kind of
beat the [__] out of him in the
Hulkbuster suit right he never caught
out this is true yeah you're right yeah
you're right well like no like at the
beginning of infinity War they didn't
have that little tussle but I feel like
Thanos having the power oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I feel like Thanos having
the Power Stone did might have given him
an advantage over
um the Hulk I'm talking no no stone
pianos yeah because this is bare knuckle
boxing this is no no
no gauntlets no nothing and I'm talking
Hulk as smart Hulk smart Hulk smart
smart Hulk level
Hulk and Thanos no power Stones yeah so
he's still a Titan yeah like I feel like
that would be a really good match
especially now that like Hulk has a
Bruce and Hulk have a better
relationship smart Hulk versus no
Gauntlet Thanos and I say uh Thanos wins
in a split decision all right yeah I
thought I could totally see that I'm
taking another dub uh what do you think
Whitney okay
no powers I'm gonna go for I want to see
drunk Jennifer Walters fight no power in
his suit Moda
that would be a great little fight
because she can't she's not good at
fighting when she's drunk and Modoc with
no power to fly he would just have to be
like me and like slapping people like a
helicopter his little arms wouldn't
reach very far so he'd have to like yeah
um I'm really sorry for everyone
listening to this is a podcast who can't
see them no this is the power of
imagination it'd be ridiculous it's our
imagination
picture picture a little a little egg
tiny arms trying to slap the [__] out of
a drunk lawyer and that's what I'm
picturing right now
Jennifer Walters would win ultimately
because he's this is true he's a little
egg she's gonna win drunk Jen Walters is
gonna come through yeah he's Humpty
Dumpty she just has to knock him
he doesn't have king's horses or King's
Men as far as I know
uh but yeah I like this silly idea of uh
Jennifer Walters slapping Modoc around
on the ground just slapping power down
there so I'm gonna give Whitney the
Rogue question Medallion of the day
here's your medallion yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I won the three bags
with me uh winner winner three bang
dinner but that is it for this episode
of Rogue Fury thanks to Our Guest
Whitney van lenningham and Tommy Beck
told you guys are amazing I love
chatting with you guys and going rogue
support our Channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at New
rockstarsmerch.com and you can follow me
at match retainment I'll Follow You
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube love you guys and we'll see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]